one problem 138 at a loading dock each
worker on the night crew loaded 3/4 as
many boxes as each worker on the day
crew so it means that the boxes per
night crew worker is equal to 3/4 the
number of boxes per day crew worker fair
enough if the night crew has 4/5 as many
workers as the day crew so the night
crew workers but this is the the number
of night crew workers that's going to be
4/5 times the number of day crew workers
fair enough
what fraction of all the boxes loaded by
the two crews did the day crew load so
how many boxes will the day crude load
the day crude is going to load the
number of day crew load workers times
the boxes per day crew worker and they
want to know what fraction of all of the
boxes loaded is this so that will be the
numerator the denominator will be all
the boxes loaded so all the boxes loaded
are going to be the boxes loaded by the
day crew so that's the number of workers
times the boxes per worker plus the
number of boxes loaded by the night crew
well that's going to be the number of
night crew workers times the number of
boxes per night crew worker and to
simplify this if we could just
substitute these variables with things
that look a lot more like that and lo
and behold we have easy substitutions
they tell us what the sub n is the boxes
per night for worker and they tell us
what the number of night crew workers
are in terms of the day care worker so
let's just substitute so this is equal
to day crew workers times boxes per day
crew worker / day crew workers x boxes
per day crew workers + what is the
number of night crew workers it's W sub
n but that's the same thing as 4/5 W sub
D 4/5 W sub D and then what are the
number of boxes per night per worker
well that's 3/4 times the boxes per day
crew worker times 3/4
it's the boxes per day co-worker see the
forest cancel out forest cancel out and
actually could simplify this we can
divide the top and the bottom by this w
sub D times B sub D and you get 1 over 1
plus C all of these cancel on your
discipline with 3/5 3/5 that's equal to
1 over C 1 is 5/5 so that's 8 fifths
which is equal to 5 over 8 and that is
choice C next problem
139 a restaurant meal cost $35.50 $35.50
and there is no tax if the tip was more
than 10% but less than 15% so the tip
was greater than 10% but less than 15%
of the cost of the meal then the total
amount must have been so what's the
range for the tip 10% of 3550 well
that's just going to be 355 and 15%
there's a couple ways you could think
about you could say it's half more than
this right what's half of this half of
this is a dollar seventy seven and a
half is that right yeah so dollar
seventy seven and a half I think that's
right
177 and a half really I mean you can't
get a half set is that right two times
that you get two and then two times
seventy is a dollar forty yeah that's
right right so this would be 5% I just
took half of this some people some
people do half of 10% if where you live
taxes 10% you could just take 50% of it
well anyway I don't wanna get into that
so let's see if you add this to this you
get 4 let me go the other way 5 12 13
and 5 so the tip is going to be between
355 and $5
33 I guess we could say right and so the
total bill right that's what they want
to know we just add both of these so I
add minimum you're gonna pay see what's
this plus $35 so 35 50 and 355 five and
nine thirty nine oh five thirty nine oh
five and at the high end you have thirty
five fifty and then you have five thirty
three and that is equal to three eight
zero one four okay so the tip so your
total bills gonna be between thirty nine
dollars and I don't know forty-one
dollars and that is exactly choice B
they just round up this a forty one is
here and thirty-nine is here so your tip
is that's between these two numbers it's
definitely between 39 and 41 and that's
choice B problem 140 in a weightlifting
competition the total weight of Joe's
two lifts was 750 pounds so L won his
first lift plus his second lift was 750
pounds
if twice the weight of the first lift
was 300 so 2 times the first lift was
equal to 300 oh sorry
if 2 times the first lift was equal to
300 more than the weight of a second
lift
so 2 times his first lift was equal to
300 more than his second lift then his
second lift what was the weight in
pounds of his first lift okay so we just
want to solve for L 1 so let's see the
best this top equation we can rewrite as
L 2 is equal to 750 minus L 1 and then
we could substitute that here so then
you get 2 times L 1 is equal to 300 plus
L 2 which is this plus 750 minus L 1 add
l 1 to both sides you get 3 L 1 is equal
to
300 plus 750 that's 1050 and 3 goes into
1050 c3 3 times 3 is 9 15 3 goes into 15
5 times it's 350 so his first lift was
350 pounds and that's choice D problem
141 a club collected exactly 599 dollars
from its members if each member
contributed at least $12 what is the
greatest number of members the club
could have so at least $12 so the more
that each member contributed the smaller
that the greater number the number of
people in the club but let's see if each
member contributed at least $12 so what
is the greatest number of members the
club can have so if they all contributed
let's say they all they all contributed
exactly 12 dollars so 12 goes into 5
well this is 12 goes into 12 goes into
60 into 650 times right so if this
number were $600 if this were $600 you
could say oh well if if you if if if
$600 were collected by in increments of
$12 at least $12 and you could have at
most 50 people right at most 50 people
but we don't have $600 right $600 would
be 50 times 12 we have 599 dollars so
this could be done 599 dollars can be
done by at most not 50 people but at
most 49 people 49 people and let's think
about that let's make sure that that's
right so my answer is 49 which is C and
let's think about how much money would
be left over so 49 times 12 this is just
a reality check 49 times 12 2 times 9 is
two times four is eight plus one is nine
zero forty nine eight eighteen five
eighty five eighty eight right so if you
have forty nine people and they all
contribute twelve dollars exactly you'll
raise five hundred and eighty eight
dollars right and then you could have
had a couple of other people I don't
know you could have had eleven other
people who instead of twelve dollars
they paid $13 and that's how you get to
five ninety-nine right because they say
at least twelve you can't have fifty
people because fifty people if they
contribute at least twelve you would
have to raise at least six hundred
dollars so it can't be fifty see answer
is 49 and you might say hey so how did
you you know why did you go to
immediately six hundred and a lot of
times on the GMAT when they have these
numbers that are you know twelve and
$5.99 those are strange number you say
well $5.99 is awfully close to 600 let's
see if I could use that information to
deduce something interesting about this
problem anyway next problem 142 of the
3,600 employees of company X 1/3 are
clerical so clerical is equal to
one-third times 3,600 which is equal to
1200 if the clerical staff were to be
reduced by 1/3 what percentage of the
total number of remaining employees
would then be clerical okay we're gonna
reduce the clerical staff by 1/3 so how
many people are we going to get rid of
so 1/3 of 1200 is what it's 400 so the
clerical staff is now going to be sorry
it's not going to be 1200 minus 1/3
minus 400 which is equal to 800 so what
proportion of is this of the remaining
employees so clerical is 800 and how
many remaining employees are there are
there 3,600 well no we've gotten rid of
400 employees who were clerical so now
we have 3,200 employees all right 3,600
minus 400 so that is equal to 1/4
one fourth and that's a 25% problem 143
140 mile continue this in the next video
see you soon